the the main approach of the good life
movement is that we are doing uh
political awareness and organizing for
mental health and so what that means is
you know we're trying to get the people
more involved in the politics of mental
health specifically and the way we're
doing that is we're coming out with um
like a bigger vision of how we can solve
the problems and a clear plan on how we
can fix the crisis uh the care crisis
the HQ of our team is going to create
scorecards and hold every single
politician accountable and say hey like
here's the plan we have like five to ten
percent of the people in your District
now we've created a strong mental health
voting block we've rallied the people
like here's a voting card here are the
policies that me and the rest of the
gang at the mental health field have put
together like where do you stand on it
92 percent of Democrats 92 percent of
Independence and 94 of Republicans all
say we need to be doing more on Mental
Health we have the voters they're going
to hold you accountable what's the plan
are you voting yes or no on this bill
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to Ford the
originator of the math hat the number
two employee in Yang 2020 and now the
founder and head of the good life
movement brand new Andrew Frawley
welcome Andrew yes thank you very happy
to be here Andrew you and I have known
each other for years ever since you did
join our janky little campaign as the
second employee what made you join a
campaign that barely existed for
president of a guy that no one had heard
of yeah it was definitely a leap of
faith
um when we first met I was living in San
Francisco and I was very passionate
about mental health and automation I
thought
um you know automation was going to
change our society and economy and that
was going to have very negative effects
on Mental Health
and super randomly I was visiting New
York City and met you and you were
talking about mental health and
Automation and I was like oh my gosh
like what a what a what a match made in
heaven and I thought Universal basic
income was a super powerful idea for
building the security of the people and
obviously that that has a huge impact on
the mind so you know I was 23 I didn't
really have many other options in my
career you don't say that I was you know
I was looking around and I said well you
know this is a big idea a smart guy
um you know it's a moon shot but let's
go for it well you were integral early
on remember you and I were scrapping and
hustling driving around some rental car
uh I remember you being one of my early
hype men or hype people where you
introduced me at a workplace right A
co-working Space in San Francisco I went
all in yes and then we were on a tour
together and I remember showing up to
that
venue and there were these math signs
that you had originated you you were the
first merchandise head of Yang 2020. I
didn't think anything of it honestly I
was like oh math that's cool and then
people started picking them up and
waving them and it became this massive
thing what inspired you to try and even
invest frankly like you know hard-earned
campaign money in a math sign
well
I mean I guess the idea around math
really is that it was a symbol of
thinking for the campaign like it was a
huge focus on you know the numbers and
really improving lives and not really
getting caught up in what so often feels
like a circus in politics
it was an absolute Focus razor focus on
you know the mechanisms that are going
to improve the lives of people and
people people agreed with that they kind
of seemed to resonate yeah well it
certainly took off man I think we we
sold several million dollars worth of
math hats alone uh much less overall
merge so thank you hundreds of thousands
of them it was uh quite the treat no and
thank you to everyone who contributed to
the campaign uh raised tens of millions
and went on to compete on seven debate
stages thanks to folks around the
country but really thanks to folks like
you who bought in early and formed the
core of our little team that grew
um what a what a journey we had my
friend what was your craziest memory
from the trail aside from any of the
stuff I just said since none of that
stuff's that crazy
I mean without a doubt it was you know I
forget what they they changed the name
of it but I think it was the Johnson
Johnson dinner in Iowa which is when
um all of the candidates came together
for this sort of Final Super Bowl moment
in Iowa and you had you know I was with
you backstage I was doing photography at
the time and you know we came across
paths with like you know Kamala Harris
and Joe Biden and Michael Bennett and
you know it's one of those moments where
you're sort of looking around and you're
like
how am I here like how did we get here
um especially given the humble
beginnings like we had started an
apartment with this pipe dream of like
basically free money to the people and
yet here we were you know with a good
message that
threaded the needle perfectly and we
were you know hanging out with now the
president of the United States is called
the liberty and justice yeah they
changed the name yeah
in uh Des Moines Iowa uh I remember that
night well
um my wife Evelyn was there so that was
glorious fun and that was relatively
late in the campaign that was wow maybe
January because Iowa voted in February
uh and then after the campaign ended you
went to work on the Bloomberg campaign
briefly but
simultaneously you are already
originating what now has become the good
life movement yeah I mean I um
you know the good life movement is
something that has basically been
percolating in my mind
since 2016 like when I was working with
you know thinking about your campaign I
was already thinking about the systems
of how do we improve mental health but
the journey goes back all the way to my
childhood where I grew up in Northern
Virginia
um which uh you know is a sort of
wholesome
American suburb I guess and my family
was sort of a product of the American
dream a bit like my father's uh blue
collar uh High School educated painter
who spent years painting walls until he
could work his way up and buy ownership
into a small business and my mother was
a stay-at-home mom PTA you know things
like that
um and our life was like this sort of
like commercial uh sales pitch for like
the suburbs like we were this family of
four modest suburbs diverse Public
Schools like Chili's on Friday and a
movie but the reality is that like
this like
facade of the dreamy suburbs is so often
uh just that it's a facade and under it
is so frequently these uh aching souls
and I've sort of come to see that as a
like feature and not a bug of like the
American system that seems there's just
so much profit off of our uh anxiety you
know my teens I had a uh my mental
health began to deteriorate very early
on I couldn't keep up with the like
meritocracy of the educational system
and then I was diagnosed with ADHD and
sort of stigmatized for that and began
to crumble a bit
um and then unfortunately my parents
divorced and that just sent me into a
total spiral I spent
you know roughly five or six years
basically clinically depressed in my
mother's basement angry playing World of
Warcraft for 60 hours a week uh making
memes and like stabbing you know spider
crickets that would jump around the
basement
um and worst of all I developed an
eating disorder uh I weighed 300 pounds
the age of 14.
and developed a form of OCD called
trichoticomania where you basically just
like rip out your hair and so I was this
image of like what today is so commonly
the
like struggling young men
um the guy Ludy had bald spots in my
hair and I weighed 300 pounds I had two
friends I wanted to vomit when I would
go into the lunchroom
um and I rebounded a bit but
very unfortunately I began to medicate
in new ways and got caught up in the uh
drug and opiate crisis and
like my friends and I we would raid
um my parents I don't even know any of
this but
um you know we would read medicine
cabinets at House parties and make bowls
of mystery drugs and just take
handfuls basically and unfortunately
some of my friends continued on that
path some of them ended up on fentanyl
um and some of them passed away and you
know I still to this day I'm traumatized
by that and
um you know the the very sad part about
all that is you tell yourself you're
um you know just doing it for the fun
and the high at the time but the reality
is sometimes you are it's not that you
want to die but you're willing to die
just to like feel something and this is
unfortunately so common in the country
um like the seemingly happy Suburban
home that crumbles is like fundamentally
American at this point and uh that's
it's just the heart of so much of the
crisis and what we're doing and it's
that is what sort of set me on this
quest for the good life movement is I
didn't even realize it for 15 years I've
been trying to basically understand how
how are we so rich in a country uh that
seemingly has it all so figured out and
yet our people are so sick that like
this is what's happening yeah I I love
the idea behind the good life movement
because when I was running for president
I would say to people all the time we
have record high GDP and at the time
stock market prices what else are at
record highs anxiety depression uh
overdoses suicides pretty much every
sign of people suffering is also
skyrocketing and by the way this is
pre-coveted now covet has been this uh
factor that has reduced life expectancy
both directly and indirectly I said to
you before we sat down for the interview
it's like hey are we all losing our
minds because that's the way a lot of
people certainly feel uh and you were
inspired to to say look there should be
a political movement around mental
health and of course they're 100 should
be yeah
the the radical thing about mental
health right now is that it's the cause
that pretty much everyone is for and so
just to paint a little bit of a picture
of the the crisis and the lifestyle and
stuff is like
some people are still unsure if we even
have a crisis and the numbers are no
because I mean everyone knows I'm
freaking miserable we have
one in five Americans this year will
have
um a mental illness less than half half
of them will get treatment you know
suicides
um are up 25 in the last 20 years while
they're going down in other countries
among youth you know it's 84 depression
is up a thousand percent in the last 50
years and then
you the thing that nobody's talking
about with the crisis is so much of the
root of it right you know I have my
anecdotes in it but it's it sort of
bears out in the numbers which is you
know when you look at it you have social
media is running around completely
unregulated you have you know wealth
inequality and all of this
um you know you have climate change our
political system is also like so you
know broken and fragmented that it's
like eroding the base of like hope and
optimism in the country and this is all
while like our lifestyles are falling
apart like our communities our homes you
know 40 of Americans say they're lonely
49 of Americans have less than three
friends 67 percent of Americans say
their job they're not engaged at their
work in work 22 say their job's
completely meaningless and what blows
people's mind is 90 of Americans still
uh commute and so people's day-to-day is
like they sit in traffic they go they go
to a job they look at a screen they come
home look at a smaller screen or if not
a screen maybe they're they're there uh
in a food service job or a security job
or something where you know you
necessarily have to commute
yeah the the I've called it the
immiseration of the country where just
people are miserable yeah and our system
is stretching us out in different ways
the the simplest way to think about it
is look let's say we had relatively
stagnant incomes for a generation or so
20 years uh and then the cost of Health
Care went up the cost of Education went
up the cost of housing went up and so
even from those things alone people
would be pretty sad because you'd be
like hey my I've been running in place
and my kids are going to be worse off
one of the stats that I I found very
compelling is that if you're a
non-college educated American the odds
of you getting married are now less than
50 percent it's like 46 and as someone
and I'm married and have two kids uh
you're single as far as I know
um but I'm going to suggest that a
society where people don't regard
marriage as something that's going to
happen to them yeah is is probably not
heading in a positive direction no it's
not great yeah I mean you know there are
people who have alternative
arrangements and the rest of it and like
you know I'm very open-minded but but
big picture like you know people giving
up on starting families with a committed
partner in that sense and I again I know
there are people that are committed
without being married etc etc but that
there are all of these very disastrous
Trends and numbers and uh I've been
another huge number that is driving me
to distraction nowadays which is what
the good life movement is trying to
address is that 70 80 percent of us can
be for something and nothing happens
like the relationship between
public approval or public sentiment and
policy is at this point next to
non-existent
it really is let's change it man change
it
well I mean as far as you know solving
the electoral system that's you know so
it might seemingly up to up to the
forward party but once you do that we'll
we'll solve all the mental health
problems
so this was like one of the things that
I thought about with the good life
movement is you know I was looking
around I was like so we have this big
crisis now covet has hit we're talking
about a lot like why are we not actually
making progress on Mental Health like
why is this not like a main topic in
politics why does it not have this equal
pressure there should be a giant
freaking interest group movement behind
it where if you're a legislator in your
full mental health and you win and if
you're not on board with various Common
Sense measures and you lose yeah I mean
that is basically what we are coming out
for so uh the the main approach of the
good life movement is that we are doing
uh political awareness and organizing
for mental health and so what that means
is you know we're trying to get the
people more involved in the politics of
mental health specifically that we have
this big Movement Like I said
um lots of energy but it hasn't
translated into like the action and
accountability to our politicians and
the way we're doing that is we're coming
out with um like a bigger vision of how
we can solve the problems and a clear
plan on how we can fix the crisis uh the
care crisis the hope is that we can
rally the people
um build a big movement and then funnel
that very intentionally into uh like
smart you know advocacy given how the
system is actually structured now which
has an outsized emphasis on the
primaries funnel that very specifically
into you know calls letters you know
office visits demonstrations with the
goal of getting those politicians just
to be held accountable uh for their
votes uh for their funding you know how
they approach mental health and so you
know our the HQ of our team is going to
create scorecards and hold every single
politician accountable and say hey like
here's the plan we have like five to ten
percent of the people in your District
now we've created the strong mental
health voting block we've rallied the
people like here's a voting card here
are the policies that me and the rest of
the gang of the mental health field have
put together like where do you stand on
it 92 of Democrats 92 percent of
Independents and 94 of Republicans all
say we need to be doing more on Mental
Health we have the voters they're going
to hold you accountable what's the plan
are you voting yes or no on this bill so
that is ultimately what we're trying to
do love it and uh yeah rallying the
people
um yeah you want us to transition from
uh GNP gross national product to gross
national well-being yes gnw which would
be an incredible step up and it would
also highlight how poorly we're doing
where now we are 30th in the world in
life expectancy public education clean
air and clean water things that you know
would probably lead you to be
less unhappy you know I'm going to
suggest so uh let's
posit that we have this new Benchmark
and it shows how miserable we are what
are the evidence based
measures that actually would make us
happier and healthier like if if you
were running in let's say a Democratic
primary Republican primary like what are
we trying to get them on board with so
obviously the big picture like you said
is like we want to get them on board
with
um the me one of the big ideas of our
organization which is uh gross domestic
well-being because like you said so much
the problem is that we chase money we
have this false belief that money is a
good enough proxy to the good life yeah
and messed up it Bears out in the facts
and numbers that's just like not the
case money does have an impact on
happiness but the numbers have shown
that every dollar you have has a lesser
impact on your happiness wait so just to
put a
number on that the studies I've seen
showed that your happiness goes up
significantly as you make more money up
to approximately seventy five thousand
dollars and this data is a couple years
old so you could probably inflate that
you know the current things let's call
it 80 80 000 and then the dollars after
that don't tend to affect your
well-being as much is that what you mean
that is exactly it so every dollar you
have after a threshold
um has a lesser impact on your happiness
and man someone gives me a dollar right
now I'm like [ __ ] you well they've
actually found it it's even logarithmic
so the amount of joy that you gain let's
say going from forty to eighty thousand
dollars in income to get the same units
of joy you now need to make 160 and then
320. so it starts to become much harder
to get the joint happiness that you need
and like you said there is an inflection
point and it's between 75 and 105 000
somewhere in there and so
you know the the big idea is that we
just need to recognize that like as a
society that you're chasing GDP into no
man's land is like so much a part of the
sickness we need to make this transition
there's a professor that said something
just unbelievably powerful to me he said
one of the major problems with how we
talk about uh the Mental Health crisis
and just like the sickness in general is
that we are individualizing societal
problems because so much of it goes to
this like the incentive structures and
so many people they say like hey we need
to fix Lifestyles we need to improve the
social determinants we need to you know
do these things because that's how we
solve mental health but it's like hey
how are we going to do that like until
you fix the incentives and get all
Society to smoothly roll towards like
the actual goal or at least on a [ __ ]
Baseline yeah it's like until you
actually like set your clear goal every
single just a just a park you're fist
fighting with like you know city council
and legislators because it's like it's
it's not entirely lined up and if you
actually create a clear measure then
there's like uh much more effective ways
on how you can quantify what's actually
going to bring us well-being so you
would ask this question like what are
the things it sounds like giving
everyone money would help
for many people especially because of
median income rights still rests in the
thirty thousands yeah so that's like one
of the big things about like gross
domestic well-being is it's like it
bakes in and accounts for the fact that
money does have an impact on our
well-being and happiness we don't need
to demonize it but we also need to
recognize there's more than that and a
good uh well-being measure accounts for
that and um what's incredible is the
field has found about 10 variables that
contribute to our well-being and that
can be baked into the measure do you
have those I have them memorized you
won't believe so much fun everyone
listen up use the 10 things that
determine our societal well-being
leomanas no okay I'll lay them out but
there's different measures and you can
sort of structure it how you want but
number one is Vitality which is like a
subjective sense of Vitality I think the
definitions are important with these uh
one is environmental Mastery a sense of
uh being able to control your
environment
um positive relationships
um a sense of self-acceptance a sense of
Mastery in your work and your craft and
your trade a sense of autonomy which is
basically like freedom and I always love
that one because it's like you know we
got one right like America we nailed the
freedom bucket and then a growth mindset
your perspective on the world uh
engagement and your day-to-day work so
being absorbed and just like your life
and then purpose and then Transcendence
which is basically like spirituality and
faith in a sense of awe and flow and the
key about these is that they're they're
very subjective and relative to the
person which I think is super super
powerful rather than going around and
looking at like Material World outcomes
and saying like we want people in houses
we want people fed and things like that
so so you're saying that gross national
well-being would be determined by
surveys where we measure heard these 10
self-reported qualities it very well
could be you know there's a lot of ways
that you can structure it yes um and
like for us the thing is what we're
really advocating for is just moving
away from this obsession with uh like a
disproven idea that money and GDP are
the way yeah and transition to this new
idea and we can still figure out the
details of what we want there's many
metrics I mean I could sit here and list
off like 10 different yeah because ways
to structure International standards
around uh
the happiness some of it is
self-reported they almost always use a
survey but then they can take some other
empirical data like suicide yeah that's
that's flaring up then you know there
there are problems
um life expectancy
uh anxiety and oppression rates of
use of prescription Med since I in my
opinion we're very much over medicated
in this country you know why because
someone figured out they could make
money I mean if it was the reverse then
all of a sudden you'd see a lot like a
very very different I mean it really
does go back to the incentives
um and you know like you said like
there's many ways you can structure it
and what I like about it is that you can
make it malleable to the community
because so many of these well-being
measures
they are like effectively self-reported
like how do you find Mastery and purpose
and meaning and so it can be relative to
each you know uh you know local
constituencies
um values and expression like what
well-being looks like in Texas is going
to be a little different than California
and if you set that as the goal you know
how you get to purpose or meaning and
you bring that out in your communities
is going to be different depending on
the communities so it's as far as the
specific ideas you know you can run
calculations but it's going to be a
little different for each Community but
the obvious things right it's where
you'll have green space walkable cities
like you'll probably see more remote
work paid family leave
um you know investments into keeping
families together subsidizing you know
family therapy the thing about this idea
is unpacking a little bit of the
background of it is that gross domestic
well-being being
um is produced by a currently thriving
field of economists like this isn't just
some like radical nothing other people
have been working on it and these are
countries have adopted yes like the
United Kingdom has gross domestic
well-being it was introduced by
conservative Prime Minister David
Cameron and then when they actually
instituted it when they were like
working the numbers and trying to figure
out how to make it go up they created
this revolutionary program uh to
increase access to a super effective
form of therapy for one thousand dollars
a patient
um they had 51 rates of full recovery
from depression across the UK and this
wasn't like a micro study they serviced
like 10 of the population wow I mean it
was like a huge sample I've got a
feeling that 10 or more of the US could
benefit from therapy personally
foreign
so you just rattled off a whole set of
things that it sounds like would help
make us happier and healthier and all of
those make sense I'll say that for me
some of the things that that come to
mind well for myself if I'm feeling down
one of the things I try and do is
exercise
um ideally Outdoors because that's a
double whammy and Studies have shown
because I'm into Data Studies have shown
that exposure to Nature is actually
uplifting and good for your mental
health and exercise is good for your
mental health yeah so guess what
exercising Outdoors is
probably good for your mental health
instead of people paying to join a gym
it's like we should either make you know
we should be paying you to go to the
jail or or certainly for me one of the
things you you mentioned I'm
really passionate about is trying to
find healthy outlets for men in
particular young men who are lost and if
you leave young men to their own devices
they can go down some very very negative
or destructive self-destructive or uh
externally destructive uh and one of the
things that I've found to be very very
good for getting out certain impulses or
aggression is martial arts training uh
particularly Jiu Jitsu but any martial
arts training it gives you a sense of
camaraderie and fellowship and the rest
of it and so um talking about having
like essentially like a national
uh MMA freaking program and and and in
my mind's eye too this is how crazy I
got in my mind's eye was that you'd have
champions of every Town and County and
weight class and state then you'd have
people competing and then there'd be
like this sort of national Dragnet of
badassery but I dare say this would be
about a thousand times more healthy than
whatever the [ __ ] is going on now so so
this this is one of my my dreams did I
talk that much about that particular
dream no I did not but uh but was it a
dream yes it was so like what what are
the things that you because I know
you've dug very deep into the the
research like what are the things that
would actually make people happier and
healthier just as an aside I do Jiu
Jitsu and I highly endorse it it's very
cathartic of all those things in a great
Community I mean one of the things that
they've definitely found in the science
is like
but you can actually you can uh find
happiness in like any type of Lifestyle
like Vitality is literally defined as
like a subjective sense Tom Insel the
former director of the National
Institute of Mental Health he says in
his book that mental health outcomes are
determined 10 to 15 by Health Care the
rest of it is our lifestyles and so so
much of our approach has to be this
whole person thinking like you said like
it literally includes like our diet and
our meaning and our community and our
social life and family and
transportation and housing and all these
things again which is why we're sort of
for gross domestic well-being is because
if you fight each of those battles
individually until the incentives are
not aligned you're just like fist
fighting into No Man's Land as far as
the specifics
so the the highest correlate uh to like
depression and often unfortunately
suicide is a lack of meaning and the
numbers have shown that the greatest
driver of meaning is just a sense of
belonging so the number one thing you
know that we could probably do is find
ways to increase meaning and Community
the the search for meaning is the big
one and the simplest way to substitute
something in for meaning is community in
my mind because then you can
be working alongside other people and
accomplish something that you're excited
about and proud of I will share one of
the things that we are working on
um is putting out what is what we're
basically going to call as like a
cultural Vision which is
so much of what we're discussing right
are things the government
can't really be involved in nor should
it be like creating meaning in people's
lives it's kind of a strange role for
the government
but we have to acknowledge that this is
like the root of the sickness and the
problem is it's our lifestyles and so
we're looking to basically
create a massive working group that
includes both you know researchers and
all sorts of random people who know the
answers to things but also the people
and create this sort of like
um open working group on like hey what
is the cultural Vision here where it's
like we can set a clear intent because
again if you have like the tip of the
spear is the gross domestic well-being
which is like this is what the
government can do but it that is what is
super powerful is if your government
just actually comes out and says hey
like our own well-being is like the
point the increase it's our priority the
fact that we have to like fight for that
is strange but then from there is the
trickle down where people say oh wow
like now is the time here's the like now
is the the people Century or whatever
and what like what is the cultural
Vision that we want and so we're working
on putting that together because so much
of it like you said it's it's these
communities and tribes and clubs and
things like that and it's like how do we
do that I I like it's it's it's complex
but so much value is gained in like
having a clear goal and a clear place to
go so you know for the people who are
interested in like assembling the
cultural Vision like come by you know
goodlifemovement.org
[Music]
foreign
so what are the solutions that the
Research indicates would actually help
us help our well-being
so when it comes to the care system
there are probably uh I mean there's so
much that we can do but the three main
buckets are the 988 number but not just
the number but building out the entire
care system it's been like a 911 for
mental health yes so it just recently
transitioned like two months ago we uh
had only basically the 911 number now we
have a 988 number for uh mental health
crises substance use even and so that is
basically just a number right now and
the effective solution is building out a
care Continuum and the the best part
about this is if we build up how many
continues have a 988 number now
technically everyone but
there's Regional call centers all around
the country and if one region doesn't
have the capacity it just gets wired to
another state but again the the 988
number right now is uh primarily uh peer
Specialists with some training
um but that's all it really is your
optimal solution is that you actually
build out carry on uh like mobile crisis
teams where you have like a psychiatric
nurse a peer specialist and um clinical
social worker and those are obviously
fantastic models where right now if
someone is in crisis and the person on
the number can't help them solve it
rather than calling the police who has
no training in it and nowhere to take
them they call them a 988 number you
know the 24 7 mobile van shows up and
they help talk them down the social
workers speaking with the family it's a
much better picture it also obviously
saves money they've rolled this out in
Maricopa County Arizona and they've been
able to shift 37 police officers off of
mental health Duty onto like solving
crimes while also saving hospitals 37
million dollars and if someone is is in
a terrible crisis and the mobile crisis
team can't solve it we need to build out
uh what are called like Behavioral
Health
urgent care clinics so it's very similar
to like what we have in New York City
City MD where something urgently comes
up there's no way you can go and get
access
and we don't really have these in the
mental health care System much at all
they do exist but it's it's very spotty
we have one of the leading models are
called ccbhcs which doesn't you know
that's a whole jargon but the point is
we have about 400 of them which is very
limiting and those are tremendous
centers that have integrated Coordinated
Care where you know you have
psychologists and therapists and uh you
know all the medications for substance
use overdose and so if someone goes in
there there's someone who can talk them
down who can give medicine there's even
sometimes Physicians who can have a
medical overhead approach and that is
like the vision for the care system
overall rather than like stumbling
through this care system people this is
something people don't realize is that
mental health care treatments are
actually super super effective part of
the problem right now is that they're
not delivered in the way that they
should be delivered 85 percent of
psychiatric drugs are prescribed by
people without psychiatric backgrounds
and that's not a knock on like the
primary care physicians and nurses doing
that the problem is that people don't
have access to the actual psychiatrists
and Physicians and so they have to get
care where they can but good care is
very intentionally timed you're focusing
on like this drug this timing then you
bring in this type of talk therapy with
this type of therapist you have the
overhead of the physician like that is
the vision of like what care can be and
so we need to build out not just the
care Continuum but then you know have
that sort of like integration that comes
with that the second thing a big
solution is obviously taking on the
insurance companies to increase access
and reduce costs just the cool truth is
that many uh insurance companies are
just like blatantly discriminating
against mental health so they if if
you're a psychiatrist or a therapist or
whatever they reimburse you at much
lower rates and so basically these
people can't run their business if they
take your insurance like they literally
can't you know pay their staff what ends
up happening is that they only take out
of pocket
um out of pocket patients which
consolidates them into basically like
affluent neighborhoods and so you have
these radical disparities in Access
where it's right now 55 percent of the
counties in the United States don't have
a single mental health uh psychiatrist
psychologist or social worker 73 percent
of counties don't have a child
psychiatrist at all I mean at all I mean
we we have this huge crisis and the
numbers are so bad that uh an 18 year
old can get a gun faster than they can
get an appointment with a psychiatrist
and so so much of that problem is again
the disparities in um like insurance and
the thing is this is super illegal in
2008 Patrick Kennedy I swear that family
has been like on the mental health game
Patrick Kennedy passes uh this
legislation among other legislators in
D.C that made it completely illegal and
insurance companies must cover mental
health equally to physical health and
yet they're just like not listening they
just don't really follow the law and so
I actually
um have connected with a top official
here in New York state who is working on
holding Medicaid uh insurance companies
accountable for uh basically like
stealing money from people who are
trying to make claims for their mental
health care and in the last few years
just New York State alone just Medicaid
he found them stealing over 230 million
dollars and they're using that money to
buy the votes to prevent the
accountability to hold them uh
accountable because I mean it's just
ridiculous companies denying these
claims because they fall into something
of the gray area where it's like yeah
you know in their minds I mean what
you're saying is look mental health is
health and I think everyone can agree
with that yeah mental health is
definitely health and so you know we
basically just need to enforce the laws
that we have and we can solve that
problem and then the third thing that we
really need to focus on is just
obviously our youth uh you know youth
outcomes as mentioned are tremendously
uh bad coming through covid 44 of our
youth uh feel a persistent feeling of
hopelessness and sadness you know uh
suicide rates are up 84 in the last 10
years with an outsized emphasis on uh
young black men uh lgbtq and trans I
mean they have 3x the rates of attempted
suicides you know Latino girls had a
surge in particular that I found out
about was like that that's terrible
um they're also really strikingly bad
statistics for boys in general yes I
mean it's again like this very much is
the everyone cause I mean when you look
at the numbers it's sometimes a little
different like what exactly like what's
what's the exact poison but everyone is
struggling and we have the answers to a
care system
um you know with youth it's like there's
so many obvious Solutions one of the
major things that the whole mental
health field is supporting is just
teaching life skills in school yeah one
of the most invigorating things is that
the mental health field has like many of
the answers and when I first began this
journey into this organization before I
even committed to it I I spent months
and months determining if we actually
had the answers and we totally have it
between the 988 number building out the
care system taking on the insurance
companies to reduce costs increase
access and then securing Our Youth and
improving our school system and and
strengthening the family system with a
larger cultural Vision right the gross
domestic well-being and this
trickle-down of the incentives like this
is actually how we can begin to shift
the direction of the crisis into
actually moving us not just out of
Crisis but towards like a more abundant
like flourishing society and it's like
not something that'll obviously happen
overnight
um it's not a Panacea but this is
um like this is all obtainable it's like
not far out I mean this is a bipartisan
cause that everyone loves that people
are ready to go to war for it don't you
mean try parts
[Laughter]
yeah it's interesting when you say it's
like hey you want to be pro-mental
Health the first thing someone might
think is okay we need to invest in
psychologists psychiatrists beds yeah uh
therapeutic environments
um but you're thinking much bigger than
that yeah well it's
again it's like when I thought I was
going to be the outlier but I have spent
for context I soft launched this
organization roughly six or seven months
ago and I took I had written a white
paper and I took the message around the
mental health field to like shop around
the ideas
um and I was met with like resounding
excitement not just in the idea of
creating a clear Organization for the
people to Rally together and fight for
mental health but actually in this
broader Vision the ex-director of the
National Institute of Mental Health of
12 Years wrote a book where he basically
says like
to really solve the problem we need to
think like whole person population
health I mean I recently spoke with the
CEO of the American Psychological
Association Dr Arthur Evans and he said
the number one thing or contribution
that your organization could make to
this field is bring this bigger Vision
to the people of population health
because so much of how we're solving the
problems right now is that we're
focusing on on like the care system it's
like trying to solve a whole crisis by
only building hospitals well if you make
the point of the economy our well-being
then everything ends up being an
investment if it improves your
well-being and right now you see it as a
cost
then it's uh yeah then it ends up
reversing things I think about the good
life movement as the March for our lives
of mental health is that a fair
uh it is fairly accurate
um I I don't know the details of what
they do it is fairly accurate we're
going to do much more education around
the topic
um like I said we have to bring this
message of a larger approach it affects
everyone from uh from people in rural
communities who are struggling when I
was in Iowa they were talking about
farmer suicide shooting up uh to people
who are struggling with uh belonging in
uh you know like any Community really
yes um for for any reason
um so I love the universality of it uh I
hope it does become a thriving political
movement that ends up pushing Us in the
right direction I would love for a
forward party to be supportive and part
of it you know what I'm actually going
to make this commitment right here we're
going to put pressure on the Democrats
and Republicans by saying the forward
party is with the good life movement so
now you've got one of three and then the
other two now will be like oh snap like
if we want to get the 92 percent of the
voters out there who want this like we
have to get on board too
it would be tremendous it really is that
everyone cause
um I mean it affects everyone in
different ways but like you said from
Farmers to Veterans to uh mothers
immigrants to trans youth to lgbtq to
you know among military veterans people
are coming out of foster care like you
you see among certain groups the adverse
outcomes are are much they're shockingly
prevalent yeah it's something that makes
you super sad I mean something I wanted
I want to unpack a little bit of the
background of our Mental Health Care
system because I think this will rightly
piss off a lot of people and get them
free it's probably money involved yeah
pretty pretty ready to fight so I mean
obviously mental health has always been
sort of just like discriminated against
since like the beginning of time
um I mean until even in the early 1900s
33 States sterilization was legal for
people with just mental disabilities and
mental health issues which is like
heinous in the early 1900s every
everyone with serious mental illness was
mostly being basically just like
warehoused in asylums like that wasn't
the original or the Cuckoo's Nest type
stuff yeah that wasn't the original
vision of those uh State hospitals but
that is like what they became because
the political will wasn't there it
really began the The Story begins the
1950s and 1960s JFK was looking at that
system and he was like this is like
shitty and we need to change it and the
original shift was to move to Community
Mental Health Centers which are like
sort of wholesome idea of like 16 beds
two to one staff to Patient ratio where
you can incorporate this like Community
lifestyle Improvement there's a huge
focus on routines mom mom and dad can
come by and hang out and he actually
passes this Landmark legislation in 1963
that was uh set to close the asylums and
move everyone into and build out this
huge network of this like fantastic care
system and he gets assassinated three
weeks later and so you the movement
loses its political head and Leadership
what ends up happening is the funding
doesn't really continue and yet the bill
was passed so the asylums are closed
and the mental health centers are never
built and we go and so we go from 95 or
95 of our public beds are still to this
day gone we went from 337 beds
uh per 100 000 residents to 12. for
public beds and if you're wondering like
where did those people go it manifested
into two of the crises that we talk
about most today which is mass
incarceration and the homelessness uh
crisis where the numbers are people who
are homeless or unhoused have a 20 to 25
rates of serious mental illness which is
500 percent times the rate of the
general population and then in your jail
system the jail system is ridiculous as
far as like how it relates to mental
health similarly 20 to 25 percent
are the rates and we have 10 times the
amount of people with serious mental
illness in our jail system versus our
state hospital system wow in 44 States
there's more people
um in the jails than the state hospital
system and Los Angeles County Jail is
our the nation's largest mental health
provider and this is all to the tune of
you know 33 000 per inmate
um per year and 21 this this is the stat
that just rocked my world 21 of all
police time is spent answering calls
regarding serious mental illness 21 of
all time I mean that's like billions
maybe tens of billions of dollars and so
um if you're wondering like why didn't
we fix it since then Jimmy Carter
actually tried to solve the problem in
the 70s he makes this big campaign
creates a Consortium in 1980 he actually
passes the legislation with Ted Kennedy
Reagan gets elected and he's like no
it's a moral failing people are weak
drugs are bad repeals the whole thing
again cuts off the head of the mental
health field and he literally banishes
the mental health and uh psychological
team that was a permanent fixture in
Carter's White House in the West Wing he
banishes them and so you you ran for
president saying like we need a
psychologist in the white house we we
actually used to have that we used to
have that and then Reagan banished them
and not only did that you know kill the
momentum of the field it actually
reinvigorated the stigma and it stalled
the field and so
we've basically had like no major
developments at least at the federal
level for 40 years and so we have like
40 years of Innovations we had the
answers 40 years ago and we still
haven't even like you know been able to
implement that what we had 40 years ago
nonetheless the innovation in the new
ideas sense and so we have you know I
feel bad for the people in the mental
health field they've been like fighting
like hell underfunded under-supported
with the answers like hey please can we
fund this stuff we know what we need to
do we'll solve the care crisis
and nobody's been listening but now it's
not a good life movement moment here to
change it no so I I dream about a
positive unifying political movement
that will result in people's lives being
better and you are building just that my
friend I am so proud of you and happy I
was going to say happy for you I mean
you have a lot of work ahead but like
happy to to support you in any way that
we can so that you actually get some of
these things implemented in real life
because even having gross national
well-being that would be a major step
but if we can start providing the
resources uh and the answers to some of
these problems that we can all see
getting worse around us like that that
is truly the way out if someone wants to
help Drive the movement and help it
succeed uh where should they go well
they should go to
goodlifemovement.org
and donate one dollar because right now
the
entire establishment the media
celebrities influencers Advocates like
I've talked to all these people and
they're all looking for the thing that
they can bet on to help lead this the
people to beat this crisis Implement
these Solutions and enhance our
lifestyles and this is the organization
nobody else is doing this like this is
the reason I am building the good life
movement is I looked around in 2021 and
I was like why is no one doing this this
is the super obvious movement super
obvious so if people donate one dollar
it's basically an endorsement of the
ideas and visions and then you know you
know we're small and volunteer driven
right now but if we have five or ten
thousand just one dollar donors uh
through the winter and into the early
spring suddenly all the media and all
the establishment they look around and
like oh like how the hell did they do
that that's a lot of people this is the
thing that I just wake up to excited
every day where it's like this is so
obvious like we have the people we have
the plan we have like The Willpower like
what are we doing all we need what are
we doing the people down indeed Andrew
one dollar for mental health I think is
a very very reasonable ask and I
guarantee that if someone donates a
dollar they'll get more than a dollar
back just out of the satisfaction of
knowing that they're part of something
so positive I can't wait to work with
you on this and to see you build this
movement into something that improves
the lives of millions of people here in
in America around the world well good
luck movement man who could be against
that not this guy who's for that I'm
gonna donate my buck right now
congratulations Andrew oh hell I'll even
donate more than a buck let's go good
life movement let's build it day thank
you